here in miami four days away from super
bowl 54. joining us now a guy who's
second-round draft pick out of penn
state the philadelphia eagles ended up
being one of the best young rookies in
2012 2019 there are people who are
saying miles sanders
nfl offensive rookie of the year we'll
find out we'll find out saturday night
but miles sanders joins us now miles how
are you buddy i'm good how are you oh
we're doing great we're doing great fun
week here great to see you great to have
a chance to talk to some guys who made
an impact this year and you definitely
made an impact for the eagles thank you
thank you appreciate it second penn
state running back we had on here today
i mean saquon barker actually that's i
think that's where i'd like to start
just like i just don't i just seen him
in the hallway you just saw him too yeah
yeah he's his legs look big as always
and everything about him uh what what
what effect did he have on your game you
know that must have not been easy
sitting behind him at penn state as
talented as you are yeah um i mean yeah
i sat behind them uh i also learned from
them too you know yeah as far going
through that whole process uh just
learning really just the little things
you know stuff that happens off the
field you know just taking care of your
body that's the most important thing
really that i've seen him do as far as
even in college so right and i took that
uh
upon me to do that so and you know as
far as ian wright you know
um watching extra film all that type of
stuff
you ever been on a team before that had
so many guys that got banged up over the
course of the year nah this is the first
now after this year is definitely the
first year i had a year like this is
there any sense to it is it just bad
luck or guys wondering like are we doing
something wrong here like how do we get
to the point where all these guys get
banged up that's unfortunate you know uh
he can't really control
so aaron and the type of injuries that
we had you know there were kind of
serious injuries and long-term injuries
for certain guys so but uh i just like
the way we play even though with those
injuries so that shows a lot about our
team
what was your like rookie moment this
year where you walked on the field and
you're like oh my who's the player that
just like you think back about it now
that you just went whoa that guy was so
awesome or whatever like i know i played
julius preppers in my rookie year and i
just like couldn't get over the size of
him and his play like who's that guy
that jumps out to you right away man
forrest on the sideline watching
offense i say aaron rodgers yeah yeah uh
scary was scary watching him control the
whole game you know that's right right
on the officer team and uh as far as
defense i say bobby wagner uh he's so
smart
can't he he's it's like he knows what
you're doing before you're doing it so
uh it's hard to trick him get him out
his his gap you know as far as playing
running back you know and
uh coach dew staley he uh talks about
that all the time you know trying to
uh fake linebackers out with our eyes
you know and trying to get him to commit
to the wrong yeah so you can have a cut
back no he doesn't make too many
mistakes though does he call out the
play kind of guy oh yeah yeah yeah he
definitely won't yeah oh that's the word
i used to hate that i used to feel bad
for you guys because i'd give my running
back the ball there they guessed it
you're you're killed give me that moment
miles when you knew in your heart that
you belong at this level that you're
gonna make it in the nfl um
i mean i always always had confidence in
myself to and always
thought i belonged but um
i say those last four games you know uh
we needed those those last four wins you
know we had to go 4-0 which wasn't going
to be easy they're all four divisional
games and
uh any divisional game is a tough game i
mean every game in nfl is tough too so
but uh i think those four games kind of
really showed me a lot about me and
just knowing
that we had to really lock in and win
those games and we did that so and i
felt like i had a huge part of that it
seems like something happened in the
locker room at halftime in that monday
night and john it's 17 nothing right and
a different team came out and you guys
stayed that way all the way through the
regular season with what went on behind
closed doors that woke up the giant uh
it's just the like i said the um
the stuff that we were going against you
know back against the wall mentality
like i said we had to go we had to win
those games to get to the playoffs and
that's what we're trying to do we're
willing to do whatever we can to do that
so and i seen a whole different team
that after that second half
we know you can play running back now i
want to see you plug pepsi okay
it's your time i'm scouting you we're
gonna we're gonna grade you right here
all right what are we doing yeah i want
to hear your pepsi ricky is here
i want to hear it i want to hear
yourself sell it to me but what do you
hear on behalf of um
[Music]
like how i believe i could win it yeah
yeah and just explain the whole thing
just why you're here on the behalf of
pepsi and everything about that oh yeah
uh just excited to be here you know it's
a great opportunity for me
and a great experience for me too so i
just hope and
the lord up there is blessing me and
hopefully i can walk away with this
award you know it'll be a dream come
true i believe i can win i'm confident
myself and
we'll see what happens what are you
working on this year this offseason once
you really start focusing on
miles sanders second season in the nfl
what's the area where you want to
improve the most uh really just getting
stronger i'm getting better in the run
game i think i can always get better or
not uh
they brought me in here as a pass
catching running back so um once jordan
howard got uh banged up and sprawled you
know it was just me out there
and i was getting all the carries you
know so uh and it's different it's
different in college i'll be the first
to say that and
what's different about it uh just it's a
little faster you know like i said you
play against guys like bobby wagner who
knows where you're going already so i
mean you so you got to play faster you
know you got to play more elite
uh the match is level so um
that's about it though yeah there's no
there's no room for error no and and to
that like who tell me who who's the best
team you played this year like who's the
team you look at here's your schedule
too just to refresh your your memory
right but i think uh the best defense
that we play yeah or just in the overall
team but yeah i like to hear both like
does seattle win the best defense award
to you um
i don't even know oh this is hard yeah
i'm putting you on the spot come on
pepsi rookie of the year candidate
i say
i say the packers or or seahawks yeah
packers are seahawks those are the two
teams that jumped out to you yeah uh one
because of rogers the other one because
of bobby wagner yeah
yeah
that's right right what's the best way
you would describe your quarterback
carson once uh elite man i love that guy
and i tell i say this all the time i got
his back all that um
i think i think he's special you know
you don't get too many guys that's that
guy's a gift that he has you know he's
smart
the thing that i love about him is uh
no matter who's out there he's gonna
give you the confidence and allow you to
play out there for him so uh that's why
i like him and
uh everything that happened this year he
handled it well and i think he had one
of his best seasons this year too he
definitely did we're gonna play a game
with you all right we got a little game
guy who said this you got to guess which
one of us two idiots said this quote
about it you know enough about it is two
idiots to know who said what well i know
he does it but he's gonna take it out i
know he's not so that's why he's gonna
guess it's a damn game he knows you're
an idiot for sure right now so let's see
where it goes the first thing i thought
of is chris carson from seattle
absolutely reckless and fearless with
his body i think people will turn on the
film and go oh i wasn't quite expecting
this
yeah you know
why why was that so quick you can at
least think about it a little bit i
think maybe the other guy he just looked
at me and he said that guy seems like a
smart football mind that guy i'm not
sure about so he's never seen your film
he's never seen your film yeah
go back and find some chris sims i like
texas oklahoma
that definitely will don't waste your
time all right there's better things to
do in your life well hey miles thanks
for some of your time congratulations on
the great rookie season and good luck
with the pepsi rookie of the year also
the nfl offensive rookie of the year
coming up plenty of awards may be coming
for you and a great and bright future
for miles sanders in the philadelphia
eagles thank you so much thank you
man thanks for having me ft live right
after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports